les réunions coupé chez sony pictures
par les gars faut des idées fraîches là
en fait la suite de jumanji nommé halo
et puis arrêtez tout téléphone et de
l'autre des idées un peu tôt mais je
masse la mito il envoie des bougies à sa
femme
justement je travaille et moi j'ai un
film à savoir quand est-ce qu'on décolle
pas bah non ici on fait des champions
messieurs n'ont ni chez wyse hannon
airways a chez pilote poussé la junte et
dans une boîte il s'appelle airways mais
c'est pas du tout une compagnie aérienne
à ces chenilles comme si le quota ce
qu'on accole un oui justement là quelque
chose à boire chez google
donc vous vous souvenez forcément de
l'ancien logo balawi sans lacets toutes
ces couleurs on n'est pas des bébés
voilà et le nouveau logo google tubert
bienvenue à la toute première réunion au
installez vous voilà vous avez des
bonbons des bouteilles d'eau ou
voulaient que les stations porte à les
jeunes et fisher bienne 12 mois il faut
une stratégie stratégie agressive chez
hubert c'est qu'il ya eu à oui c'est
vrai c'est un deuxième d'accord chez
pôle emploi
bonjour je cherche un emploi
vous êtes comme ballon chercher quel
poste conseiller pôle emploi ça tombe
bien un poste bien ça libérez vous êtes
embauché le dernier été beaucoup alors
c'est pas mon genre
vous êtes viré chesnais marton petit
maillon outils chaussures on a mis des
chaussettes de rechange alors plus voyez
de ballons aussi aller je voulais pas y
aller oui bah oui bah allez salut les
amis ciao pied youtube on accueille le
nouveau crew youtuber il a deux millions
d'abonnés hockey à vous parler de la
petite starlette la petite lou elle est
là ouais c'est juste le caméraman à la
lecture des vidéos de sa propre
initiative coucou et le petit frère de
tiffert qui a bientôt faire des vidéos
tels ping il a commencé à bouger pied
moi je suis juste allée souriez les 600
millions d'adultes hub souriez jeunesse
est le buzz cette base j'ai cru qu'en
bon je vous présente le futur du
déplacement l'hoverboard
chez tf1
pardon oui je crois qu'il ya un problème
d'impression dans le logo de votre
émission parce qu'il manque une lettre
la cecc hollande
ce qui est sûr c'est que vous vous êtes
particulièrement collants excusez moi
c'est vraiment un problème au niveau de
l'alphabet regarder gbc des fc lorient
dire c'est que la promenade il vous
plait juste pour savoir allez retourne à
l'école ça suffit oui merci monsieur
brawn tu vois c'est en permanence comme
ça tous les jours
au cassé je suis désolé mais vous disais
quoi le bêtisier de donner donner leur
sang tous les jours c'est pas avec ça
parce que je le fasse maintenant tu as
les souris voilà on était un petit
prince alors on va la mettre
ce n'est pas une poubelle moi c'est
comme ça je sais pas
du sud faire des vidéos pour ce taux
atteint maintenant toi et toi arrête sur
ton téléphone de trouver des idées à pau
pour donner je pense le mytho ils ont
dit oui c'est plus équilibré
[Musique]
merci bien sûr que c'est possible
regarde machin programme depuis le début
mais non non je déconne voici chandhok
en tout début en fait aux [ __ ] et
casse toi toi [ __ ] alors on a fait
resteront sort libre enstone a alors on
a fait un bon boulot
west life russie l'eau mais justement
c'est justement en anglais tant ils
veulent manipuler là pour faire quoi
pour faire des coups mais bon si j'avoue
janot dans le mélo bois je vous vois
aussi est non et je le fais avec vous
c'est plus flou et non c'est plus que le
salaire de gérard c'est plus mon
possible pour un un téléphone bâton au
japon de la quête et non là bas si on le
v10 et a pas une bille d'or c'est pire
[Musique]
on enfourche super pratique pour des
places
les dialectes bonjour je cherche un
emploi
vous êtes au volant de crayon
[Musique]
wahaha
à bonne cause